so I thought maybe we could start
quickly just by helping me get a sense
of who's in the background I know in the
attendance I know that's kind of a mixed
crowd so how many people here are
technical uh
okay what about policy legal
and like businessy folks
okay cool great mix uh so today I'm
going to be talking about uh Dao
liability
uh
I'd want to start by talking about a
concept from this woman Carlotta Perez
who's a Venezuelan uh Economist and I
think this is a great uh analytical
framework to take when you're discussing
crypto law and policy and I think what
Carlota does in particular is she
identifies a cyclical relationship
between
law and technology and the way that this
relationship works is with every
technological Paradigm of the of the
time there develops a legal framework
that is best adapted to that paradigm
um and what happens over time then is
that when the new technological uh
Paradigm develops
it is in conflict with the prior uh
legal framework that has developed and
and therefore the legal framework acts
as an exclusionary mechanism that drives
the development of this new technology
in the fringes
so this is a little bit of a deeper dive
into Carlota Perez's framework and you
can see in the bottom left eruption is
when this new technology is born and
then there's a period of frenzy which is
where this technology is developing
attracting a lot of capital again still
kind of in the fringes of the regulatory
framework then there's a turning point
uh which is typically brought about by a
catastrophe of some sorts or some big
event that forces a realignment between
the old now obsolete regulatory
framework and the new technology of the
day and then that leads to kind of like
the Golden Era where there's like a
Synergy between the both and a maturity
so my
uh thought is that we are here
um and frankly we might even look at the
events of last summer uh leading up to
like ftx's collapse as the big event
that's potentially going to cause this
realignment between
um the regulatory framework and the
technology
uh okay so what are we gonna talk about
today uh I want to start by uh going
over the couple of regulatory
enforcement actions uh against the house
uh then I want to talk about some of the
private litigation against the house uh
and once we have these couple of
examples on the table uh try to distill
uh some themes in what we can call Dao
litigation uh and talk about how that's
affecting Taos and their members and
what they can do to protect themselves
um and I should have said this at the
beginning but I'd very much welcome
questions and interruptions and
Corrections from you guys
um
so what is like my big Point uh my meta
thesis here is uh
that we those are basically facing a
wave of litigation that could threaten
their existence and operation in the U.S
and that's because as we'll see there's
certain kind of procedural advantages
that plaintiffs have when suing Dows
that make it very favorable for them to
bring these types of claims and
unfortunately the regulatory framework
hasn't developed to the point where
Dallas are can be like fully recognized
or protected from their activities
foreign
so we're going to start off by talking
about ukidao which is notable because it
was the first regulatory enforcement
action against the Dao and it also uh
was the subject of related private
litigation uh so ukidao was formerly
known as the BC b0x protocol is anybody
here familiar with it
yeah
uh so it's it's basically like uh D5 1.0
version of like a lending protocol it
allows you to trade assets uh go long
and get some Leverage
um it was founded by a couple guys in
the United States and
um it didn't really exude a culture of
like compliance uh they uh as we'll see
later
um they like advertised heavily like
there was no kyce they ended up getting
uh hacked one of the developers was
fished and lost a bunch of uh ended up
losing a bunch of crypto in the protocol
because he had the private keys to it
um so what happened
um
oh sorry yeah this is this is also a key
Point
um
the like many D5 protocols uh it was
developed by you know a couple people in
a company in the developing company and
then later they uh issued a governance
token and basically allowed the holders
of that token to control certain admin
keys of the protocol
um
they have this like really unfortunate
quote that the cftc picked up on and
that I think has driven a lot of the
outcome of the litigation where the
founders are basically saying everyone's
getting you know sued around us like
it's really unclear what the regulatory
framework is so we're just gonna
basically decentralize as a regulatory
arbitrage strategy right
um
and it did not work out that way for
them
uh so the first thing that happened was
that the cftc sued the two Founders
um and the development company and
settled with them for a pretty modest
Define 250 000 which in cftc terms is
like a slap on the wrist
but it was a pretty curious settlement
because it basically found the founders
culpable
for behavior during two separate periods
the first period the cftc said you guys
were the owners of this company that
developed a protocol and then the
protocol basically allowed people to
trade Commodities on margin
so they were talking about Bitcoin and
ether specifically and the fact that you
could have leverage on the protocol
right and they said you know this is a
activity that is typically only allowed
to be done by what's called like a DCM
or fcm which is like a highly regulated
uh intermediary that there's no way like
a crypto startup could ever become one
so they found them liable for that
period but then they said
you were also liable for after the uh
you guys did the governance uh token
drop in the Dow had some sort of admin
key control over this protocol you were
also culpable during that period
um and then
so up to here this I think it was kind
of like an aggressive
uh you know enforcement action
particularly like that finding them
liable for that second period but
nothing kind of out of the ordinary what
I think really riled people up
was when they
uh turned around and like concurrently
also suit the quote unquote Dao
um so maybe like to put it out to the
audience why do you how would you
explain this behavior on the part of a
of a regulator if you already got the
two Founders and the development company
why would you go ahead and Sue the Dao
after
sure
participation or to say that just
because you're a doubt is a mean you're
immune from a lot yeah so I I definitely
do think it had a chilling participation
uh effective participation I don't know
if that was the goal I think the goal
was the second point that you set right
it's like in their mind they look at
that quote and they're like that says
we're going to decentralize so there's
nothing to enforce against and they're
thinking like if it's illegal to run a
DCM as a company well a sure should
be legal to run it as a doubt right so
in their mind they have this equivalence
of the role that a development company
and the kind of founders of this
protocol have with the role that a Dao
has
um
so yeah they have this this basically
this whole theory of liability is
underpinned by their conception that
there's a transfer of control uh when
the Dow token holders get some admin
rights to the to the protocol
um and then we have a quote from the
cfdc chair saying basically like this
was so egregious that we had to do
something uh we couldn't just like stand
by and do nothing right
like Dao members themselves are probable
or there's no concept of like limited
liability here or so that's one of the
key issues that we're going to drive at
but I can just address it now right
um the
critical point when discussing liability
of Dallas is that they're potentially
assumed to be an unincorporated
association or a general partnership and
that's kind of like the default business
entity that the law will assume if
people get together to do a business
without forming like an LLC or a C Corp
right they'll just say well you guys are
General partners and the real like
Draconian result of that is that then
any member
of that general partnership can be
what's called jointly and said reliable
right so if you're running a partnership
that you know creates 10 million dollars
in liability and you're the accreditor
to that or like a enforcement agency can
pick any member and say you owe me now
10 million dollars and then that member
gets the right to go fight
then ask for uh recovery from the other
members but you know good luck
recovering money from an anonymous frog
on the internet
um
so yeah that was
um that that's like the Crux of the
issue basically
um
and I guess a couple of
um other points to tease out before we
move uh how do you serve a Dao
like they don't have offices they don't
have you know addresses so what the cftc
did and this almost sounds like a joke
is they literally went on the front end
of like the Uki protocol they clicked
help and there's like a little chat
thing that pops up and they're like
here's like the complaint right and then
they also put it in like the governance
Forum
um
legally like this created a bunch of
questions as to whether that's like
proper service right because if
ultimately
what can happen is you're holding any
token holder liable for that action like
are they really going to get notice of
this lawsuit
um so a bunch of what I call Amicus so
like uh people that are third parties to
a case including first Lex Punk which is
a kind of defy advocacy group that was
funded uh from a treasury of uh was it
uh
it wasn't yourself it was the I forget I
think it was compound and one other D5
protocol
um and then d flat head fund uh as well
as two funds 200 VCS Paradigm and
Andreessen both filed amica's briefs
basically arguing that the what the cftc
has done here didn't uh meet the bar for
like proper service and we we ended up
losing on that point
um
and then I guess another key point to
tease out here is that when you're
um saying that dials are General
Partnerships or an unincorporated
association you have to basically
uh engage in like a line drawing
exercise where you've got to figure out
right like who exactly is part of the
tower right
um
what the cftc said was anybody that held
tokens and voted even once on whatever
governance proposal happened was a
member of the Dao so then you can start
thinking about all these absurd like
hypothetical situations where like what
if I you know bought a token
voted on the governance proposal to like
change the background color of like the
front end now I'm like a general partner
and like running like a unregistered vcm
but like what if you know the proposal
was like do we want to run a DCM and you
say no you're still now voted on a
governance proposal and it kind of like
dragged along right uh so there's all
these kind of weird Fringe cases that
come up
um so this might be like a little bit
nerdy uh or like too legally but um
where we are procedurally in the case
was
um and this is still all these cases are
still ongoing
um
the judge has now ruled that the Dao the
ukidao was a unincorporated association
for the purposes of receiving process
and he did that just by basically going
to the definition of unencrypted
Association in the California code
saying there were two people more than
two people you guys all agreed to form a
business when you receive these tokens
and they have like a sufficiently lawful
purpose which is to to control this
protocol right and again the the quote
in the bottom
highlights this uh theme again which is
like you know you can't evade liability
or responsibility by decentralizing
right so you hear have the the judge
saying the protocol itself is
unregistered in violation of federal law
somebody must be responsible
and
um
so I think that the key from this last
slide is just to note that uh
the ultimate liability of the Dao and
the members has not yet been determined
so far it's only at the point of like
has the service been proper so I think
there's still like a second part of this
case like the where the merits are going
to be adjudicated and so far the cftc
has indicated
um in its briefing and in oral arguments
that they really only want to enforce
whatever judgment they get against the
Dao and I presume that means like the
treasury but they're not going to try to
like go screw any individual token
holders but again doctrinally that's
where this could lead right
yeah two questions maybe up in front
yeah
yeah does cftc think that they have
jurisdiction to regulate it and not
another in other regulator or authority
elsewhere in the world yeah
so the question is uh on what basis did
the cftc uh find that it had Authority
uh to to have this judgment against the
Dao given that potentially token holders
all over the world right so that's
that's a good question it was briefed in
the
um in the amicus briefs a little bit
um and I think the
there was a little anecdote this might
be like two in the weeds
um but uh in one of the hearings uh we
were basically arguing that right we
were saying you don't know if this the
token holders are in France like how are
you going to say that this is abiding by
like the French like service of process
rules and then the cftc lawyer said no
no we know that the two Founders uh were
in the U.S right so then what the judge
ended up doing was ordering the cftc to
serve the founders in the U.S
uh for purposes of like accepting this
um
uh process and and
they got like this amazing response from
the Founder's lawyer because again like
the founders had already settled right
so the lawyer was like got your letter
as you know like we settled this like a
month ago and part of the settlement
said that they could not be uh
participating in any more dial
activities and were not authorized to
receive this process so thank you but I
can serve it right so I thought it was
like awesome and I was like hooting and
hollering when that came out but uh the
judge again I think mostly driven by
like this theory of like Equity of like
I can't just let them evade liability
um
found that the process was a
was okay I mean the other jurisdictional
hook right is the
users U.S users were able to access the
the protocol
was there a question back there I just
kind of related
so how do you like not go to jail do you
just set up like uh like like do you set
up the dial essay and like go overseas
place and then they just can't send you
something like so this is a good
reminder to give my disclaimer that I'm
not giving any legal advice
and the views here are not the views of
paradigm
um
so I'm trying to figure out what how to
give you a satisfying answer
um
so the
the question is how do you go to jail
how do you not go to jail uh and uh
basically whether offshoring the
operations Works
um so
um
I'll try to answer it this way the U.S
Regulators have like a amazingly
expansive view of their jurisdiction
um like look at
like Avi you know like uh or like they
brought a bunch of cases basically if if
any of the
products are available to us users even
if that is by a us user connecting
through VPN like in violation of the
terms and conditions of the protocol
like they will find that enough to to
find Reliable right so I don't think
um
it's it's you're not gonna dissuade them
by being Out Of Reach like there was one
amazing quote uh from Arthur Hayes uh
the bitmex founder uh who like you know
was found guilty of like AML violations
where the government
attached as an exhibit to the complaint
uh his tweet that said I'm Incorporated
in the Seychelles come at me bro
right so like they're they really they
don't take lightly to that right
um
and the other thing is like when so but
you're right like a lot of the projects
like at least knee-jerk reactions are
like it's so messy here it's so risky
that I'm just gonna go offshore that
doesn't really work unless it's like
truly an offshore
project and but I mean what I mean by
that is like you know us users aren't
able to access it even like through like
vpns
um and it's not controlled by a us
person right because there's a lot of
tax I think a
a big football that projects make is
they don't consider the tax implications
of that and there's a lot of tax rules
like ECI like effectively connected
income like pivic uh CFC uh controlled
foreign corporation laws that basically
mean that if
they're designed to avoid like you know
offshoring income to like low tax
jurisdictions so if you're found to uh
basically be controlling economic
activity outside of the US from the US
the IRS will come get you and like
charge you penalty fees so I guess the
long answer the long-winded answer is
um
going offshore is like a
understandable reaction to the
uncertainty here but it's not in my view
uh a foolproof solution because The
Regulators still think they have
jurisdiction and if you're controlling
it you're going to have tax issues or
like regulatory issues uh but yeah I
mean like I see a ton of like uh came in
foundations Panamanian foundations
currency trust every kind of you know
cycle there's like a new more exotic
flavor of it
um
but I don't think it's going to really
stop regulators
um okay so that's uh the cftc now I want
to switch gears a little bit and talk
about the SEC and maybe I should have
not presumed understanding of this but
like the cfcc is the Commodities
features uh regulator right they
regulate like derivatives and they like
basically were created to regulate
things like pork bellies and like oil
Futures and stuff like that right uh SEC
is Securities land right
um and they're like been the main
antagonist of the crypto industry and
there's also been this interesting
Dynamic where they're basically both
kind of vying for the opportunity to be
the main regulator of the crypto spot
markets which if you think that you know
crypto is going to be a huge part of the
economy from the agency's perspective
could be like a huge power grab right
so the sec's has done a lot less on
Dallas specifically but their first
thing much earlier right so do folks
here remember like the Dao hack
so this was like the slock it down right
that was like basically like a VC fund
that everybody was super excited about
it got hacked and led to the fork
between ethereum classic and ethereum
right so a few weeks after that happened
the SEC issued uh what it's called like
a 21A report which is not an enforcement
action it's just like a guidance to to
the market right and what they said was
basically
uh the
tokens in this Dao were Securities
um and they met and they were Securities
because they met the definition of
investment contract I'm sure everybody
here is familiar with the Howie test
right
um so this was basically like the first
Salvo in that whole discussion
um
and the point that they made right was
even though every and sorry I should say
the
the Howie test is this test designed to
basically determine when a Arrangement
that could otherwise look like a
commercial Arrangement really is the
Securities transaction and should be
brought under the like umbrella of
Securities Law and like all the added
disclosures and liabilities right and
what it basically tries to get at is if
you're
uh and if you're giving somebody else
money with the expectation that that
other person is going to go away and do
something else
um and because of their effort you're
going to get more money back then that
is a security
like notwithstanding what form it takes
what the ultimate like you know object
of it is and and what that means is that
the person that's taking money
should give the public a bunch of
disclosures and should be liable if they
lie about this right
um
so then the question is
what happened to everybody voting in
this right like there's not you're not
really relying on somebody if everybody
gets to vote uh on what you're doing but
what the SEC said was basically the the
voting rights that the Dow token holders
had were very limited uh they focused on
the role that this basically like
whitelist curator had who had the power
to admit proposals for the Dow and they
said since there's this kind of
gatekeeper personal role here that is
responsible with admitting or denying
any proposals you don't really have
um like a full control right of this
right uh and they also weirdly said that
because they were decentralized and
Anonymous it was going to be very hard
for the token holders to coordinate so
therefore they couldn't really like uh
they had to rely on somebody was there a
question back there
no
sorry
um
and then so we didn't hear anything
about Dallas from the SEC
until uh our friend Avi uh so are you
guys familiar with like the mango hack
that happened a couple of months ago
uh
uh so
uh this this guy Avi Eisenberg
uh basically did like an oracle
manipulation attack on Mango markets
which is a lending protocol in Solana uh
and what he did is he basically took a
position that was collateralized by
mango and then you know put a bunch of
Bits And Trades on exchanges that fed
the Oracle price to the protocol so that
he like pumped up the price that allowed
him to basically use his collateral to
just wipe out all the other assets in
that protocol and then when he stopped
manipulating the price of mango tokens
the whole thing came crashing down right
uh and then he like owned up to it
because he's like a Cody's law type of
guy
um God bless uh
and he then got arrested in Puerto Rico
like the day after Christmas or
something and he got sued by the doj the
cftc and the SEC like all dog piled on
top of it
um
and so focusing on the sec's enforcement
action specifically what they said was
uh Eisenberg violated the anti-fraud and
anti-manipulation rules because the
underlying tokens were securities
and again this is kind of like a Dao
token that allows you to vote uh not
this similar to the
um ukidao tokens right
um
and they said that the Dow was an
unincorporated business uh an uncovered
Association so similar again to to the
Uki formulation
but I think one kind of key
tension between the view that the cftc
holds and the SEC holds uh the cfdc is
telling you you guys are all General
Partners in this business because you're
voting tokens to quote unquote control a
protocol right
um
and therefore you're potentially
personally liable uh the SEC on the
other hand they want to try to argue
that they have jurisdiction so they need
to find that the underlying token is
their security but as we discussed
general partnership interest because all
the partners are voting are often
thought of as not being Securities right
because there's no third party there
that you're relying on you're all kind
of in this together so
um again similar to what they said in
the initial Dow report they basically
said that yeah yeah like you mango token
holders you have some voting Powers but
you don't really have owning power it's
because uh they're I guess not everybody
was able to make proposals they also
said that not everybody would be
technologically sophisticated enough to
make a proposal
um so briefly what was then eisenberg's
um defense I mean it seems like
manipulation pretty clearly but why did
he think that he was not acting and back
pain uh
I mean he's like a quotas law like Maxi
so he and and that seems like silly to
lawyers but there is a admittedly like
a divide into like what from what the
crypto Community or like the more kind
of extreme parts of the crypto Community
think is like fair game and what
um you know the rest of society thinks
is so that he basically said hey like I
didn't you know steal anyone's password
I didn't impersonate anybody the quote
was functioning as it was designed I was
just able to you know understand how it
would react better than the team right
and
I mean I think he's kind of arrogant and
and I'm not surprised that he got
arrested
but at the same time I kind of think
that we need people like ADI if diva is
going to be able to like be hardened
over time right because so I don't know
I'm kind of conflicted about people like
him yeah because he kind of obtains the
whole the whole Space right in a
negative light and he just was taking
advantage of just rules that aren't
written yet
uh I think it could paint this space I
think it could also make it more
resilient like make the old like
applications more resilient right
um and like if what we want to do is
develop systems that
um you know are able to
coordinate uh relationships without the
need for relying on the law to like
um
enforce those
I I'm kind of sympathetic to plea to
like you know kick the tires on
everything
um I wouldn't suggest tweeting about it
or like coming to Puerto Rico for
Christmas but
was there a question back there
all right
um so where does that leave us
in the words of Matt Levine
um it's like the world the worst of all
worlds uh because you are similar enough
to shares that you are dealing in
Securities but as you guys all know like
stock gives you limited liability but
you're also different enough that you're
kind of look like a partnership and
potentially or a general partner right
so not great
um okay so that was basically the big uh
Federal enforcement actions against
Dallas and now I wanted to tick through
a couple of the uh private ones how are
we doing on time
okay I'll try to go quick
um
and obviously like
what the federal government is doing is
directly impacting what private
litigants want to do right so the first
one here is uh pool together uh have you
guys familiar with this one this
protocol
so it's like a no loss Lottery where you
would basically deposit uh ether crypto
in the smart contract the smart contract
would then like LP on like Ave or
compound and it would get that yield
and it would basically raffle it off to
people so you never lost your principal
and you got like a chance at getting
some upside from the yield
and the plaintiff in this case was a
self-described concerned citizen who
thought that the like crypto is like
boiling the ocean
um so he bought uh like twelve dollars
worth of like he got you know twelve
dollars of some stable coin deposited
into this protocol and then sued every
in uh like the founders and all the
investors basically claiming that they
were acting as a general partnership
running this
unincorporated association which was
like an illegal Lottery
and then this same firm over time has
now brought three different uh class
actions against Dallas and interestingly
you can see how through that progression
they're like sharpening their arguments
and also pulling in from what the
regulatory enforcement actions are doing
so in this first one for example they
argue that
all the partners all the investors and
the founders are members in the general
partnership but they interestingly don't
Sue like quote-unquote partnership or
doubt right uh the next one was the
private litigation in the b0x case again
this is the same thing as Uki just like
the class action version of it and here
are the plaintiffs where people they
were like djans that had a bunch of
money on Uki and lost some of them like
up to like you know 450 000 in the hack
and then they said you guys were a
general partnership running this
business you owed us like a duty uh to
like you know run it in a safe manner
you you breach that by letting the dev
get hacked
um
uh and then this is the the latest one
to be filed
uh this one was particularly painful for
me because it named Paradigm and it was
filed the day after a holiday party so I
was like you know uh sipping a cup of
coffee with a headache trying to figure
out what we were going to do about this
um it was on a Friday too
and so what they did here was they
basically sued the compound Dow
um and like a bunch of the big named
investors and they said that it was an
unregistered offering of Securities
interestingly they focused on like the
liquidity mining program as the actual
offering
even though they didn't get any
plaintiffs that participated in that uh
the cover of the plaintiffs that they
got were like people that got like ten
dollars worth of comp by like watching
those videos on coinbase which I think
is like hilarious uh
but anyways they again you know
um
I guess there's not much more to say
about this one and and all these cases
are still ongoing and none of them have
reached like any uh resolution on the
point of whether a Taoist and
unincorporated association other than
Uki and like The Limited service context
um
so this is like the underlying claim is
uh unregistered offering of Securities
and so when you're a plaintiff in that
you basically are asking for what's
called rescission you're saying uh you
sold me something that should have been
registered but since you didn't
registered
registered I get the right to like
basically put it back to you right so
it's almost like a put right that you
get at the end yeah
I I don't see why anyone should sue for
12 dollars
um yeah so the
interesting question
um I can get pretty conspiratorial about
this because like class actions are very
expensive to to bring forward right I
think part of what explains this frankly
is
like a plaintiffs law firm that is just
being an entrepreneurial and like wants
to make this their Niche they also see
it as a big business opportunity right
if they end up getting certified so the
way that class actions work
um you'll have like the first like lead
plain tip but then you'll certify a
class right so it won't only be the
person that put ten dollars that's just
the person that files the fursuit then
they will then be like anybody that you
know contributed to this protocol ever
or like in this period gets the journey
but I do I have wondered whether like
there's some third-party financing here
uh but I don't know
um
and this is the latest fund uh patterns
rules uh so are you guys familiar with
like the patent troll industry at all
um so these are basically companies that
will buy up patents and then just Sue
tech companies uh for infringement and
it's like a pretty basic business model
right if it costs you uh less to enforce
the pattern then like you get the payout
then you make some money and you just
try to do it at scale so a lot of these
patents are frivolous oh patents aren't
valid in like the lawsuits are frivolous
but just because it's a pain in the ass
to deal with they end up squeezing money
out of people
um so uh
publicly there's been one troll that has
sued both maker Dao and compound Dao
they have this like incredibly broad
pattern that everyone tells me should
not be enforceable that basically covers
any uh off chain data uh like any Oracle
data getting pulled on chain
and they have now sued both the house
and again like
um
they're making their way down the court
the process right so
I guess this is another key point that I
wanted to uh distill from all these uh
litigations
um so why I think this is so dangerous
is because dollars don't respond because
Dao's are typically like super
disorganized they don't have like a clo
uh so when you know somebody sues a
quote-unquote Dao there's no like real
institution there to respond and because
of this limited uh joint and several
liability issue if I'm a member in a Dao
like why the hell would I want to raise
my hand to defend this right because if
I do it and I lose then I'm like first
in line to pay for everybody else uh so
what happened is this Dynamic has come
up where
plaintiffs can just file lawsuits
against Taos knowing that no one's going
to stand up and defend them they'll get
to score points while like the other
teams off the court and then once uh
when that happens right like in judicial
process if nobody shows up the judge
can't do anything other than issue with
default that basically says you know
there was a proper lawsuit and like
nobody showed up to defend it so you
lose
um
and then the plaintiffs this hasn't
happened yet but this has to be the end
goal they get that default in one hand
and then they go find
um like the Dow member that has the most
money or is like the most visible and
they go try to enforce it on them right
uh so it's a really shitty setup for
those
um okay so what are some other uh and
I'll just Breeze through these because
we're getting close on time uh other
questions uh I mean I think the question
about choice of Law and like
jurisdiction is a big one so far we've
been litigating
um in like you know Northern District of
California sdny but I think over time
especially as
these uh cases start to proceed against
individual members that are not in the
U.S these questions of choice of law are
going to become much more
uh naughty and difficult uh the service
issues too right
um so far the plaintiffs have survived
the service challenges uh but again I
think that as these cases move forward
towards individual members
there's going to be more defenses for
that
um foreign
so I think that they're like you know
main question is are Dao's some sort of
unincorporated association
um
one key way to try to analyze this is if
you think about token holders as being
kind of like joint members in the
business or whether they're just joint
owners of property because you can own
you know an apartment complex like with
your cousin or something and you're not
a general partnership as long as you're
not running a business so I think this
will still be decided
um
I think a lot of what's going to drive
this frankly is
unless there's some other theory of
liability that can find the most like
reprehensible conduct liable they're
going to end up saying that those are
unincorporated associations I think the
real question now becomes who's in like
what do you need to do to be part of
this uh general partnership is it voting
is it just holding a token is it making
a governance proposal is it like you
know passing some sort of proposal uh so
I think that's still unclear
and then another like this might be like
nerdy and and Technical but
if if the underlying theory of liability
is this is a general partnership
uh where all partners are jointly and
severally liable
then it's kind of hard to get private
plaintiffs right because if for example
on the Uki case
like those people were using the
protocol and they also had like b0x
tokens so you're basically it's like
that Spider-Man meme where like they're
all pointing at each other right because
the plaintiffs themselves could also be
potentially jointly and severaliable for
the actions of the general partnership
that they're assuming
um
um and then kind of some more
um technical ones a lot of the
regulatory strategy for D5 protocols has
been to try to push this distinction uh
technologically but also kind of uh
theoretically between like the front end
which is what the development company
will kind of control and like say
they're liable liable for responsible
for and then the the protocol which
they'll try to wash their hands off and
say oh no like that's just you know open
source software that we don't
necessarily control
there's going to be a lot of stress into
that distinction and similarly like
um
all the the whole theory of liability at
least from the cftc's perspective is
that the there's a transfer of control
between the developers of this protocol
and the token folders
um I think that's like really
a warped view of the world and like I
don't understand
uh the equivalence between those two uh
but it's clear that there's like a lot
of confusion here for example uh cfcc
chair Benham uh and like I think last
week was giving a speech about the
cftc's recent enforcement actions and in
referring to Uki he said that
he like even butchered it more he said
that the protocol had converted into a
decentralized organization
uh so like before it was like uh you
know it was the control of it now but
now it's like the whole protocol becomes
this Dao
um in my mind like when a token holder
is voting on something it's not
operating a protocol and it's not really
controlling it right like there's
obviously different levels of admin
rights that you can have to a protocol
but you're not voting to say like yes
let's open like this margin position for
this one person that's coming to our
site so I think that'll be a big
Battleground
um
so what can Dao's do to protect
themselves
uh
there's no kind of Perfect Solutions
I've done a fair amount of research into
uh like Dao wrappers which are
basically legal entities that Taos can
form
um you guys might have heard of kind of
like the Wyoming Dow laws or we talked
about kind of the offshoring structures
earlier
so I think it's an interesting area
there's a lot of kind of experimentation
there's no perfect fit and a lot of
these corporate forums especially the
more traditional ones uh introduce a lot
of restrictions into the operation of
the entity right so like
if you're a dow LLC like you can't just
become a member
of that LLC by buying a token you would
have to like sign a legal agreement
right there's a lot of issues with like
anonymity you can't necessarily preserve
anonymity in a lot of these corporate
forms
um and then I think
people also get very confused with the
offshore structures because a lot of
these structures are what's called like
owner-less entities which are basically
like a trust structure right but it
doesn't necessarily give limited
liability to the Token holders because
token holders aren't members they're not
shareholders of this entity this is just
a trust that's set up to basically
benefit some sort of purpose
um
people are are thinking about defense
funds and Trust I know that maker
Community just approve like a 5 million
die uh fund for like defense I don't
think they've uh
like put in an action yet but people are
thinking about that uh and then third
party organizations uh so there's been a
lot of kind of Amicus briefing in these
legal uh cases on the uh patent troll
matter specifically
there's been some pretty interesting uh
like patent specific Solutions uh we've
been trying to coordinate with a
organization called unified patents
which uh exist pre-crypto to fight
patent trolls and what they do is
basically they create zones where they
will admit members who will
cross-license technology to each other
and then put money in a like a pot and
then unified patents will just Sue any
troll that like messes with any other
members so it's it's basically a
deterrence mechanism by just increasing
the cost of any troll uh we'll have in
like trying to enforce against these
people so it's like a they don't kind of
negotiate with terrorists type of
strategy
um and I think that's it yeah
how did I do one time
cool so I'm happy to answer any
questions and I'll be hanging out for a
little bit after this
hi thanks for the talk
um I had a question on pool together
because that's
kind of similar to like the premium
bonds product that's in the non-block
chain
context right so what products are like
premium bonds so basically you'll put
your money into a savings account and
then you have some chance of winning
extra yield one month and that's been in
like a non-crypto like a traditional
fintech space there's been some
companies doing that
um so what about crypto makes it
different that then the SEC has some
kind of jurisdiction over that
uh
so I I don't know enough about the like
uh comp here to really answer it
um
I've so I think the underlying claim is
that it's an unregistered uh security
it's not really an SEC sorry it's an
unregistered
um
lottery so it's not necessarily uh it's
not the SEC suing them it's a private
plaintiff saying that they're running an
unregistered lottery so for I know the
these other companies that you're
talking about have
like the Required licensing to to do a
lottery in New York or whatever
um
I think the other meta point to make is
I like I hear this a lot as like
especially when I was outside Council
they're like oh how come you're telling
me I can't do this if like that person's
doing it like that's not then crypto
like that's probably because that other
person's like doing it wrong uh or like
just has
a higher risk appetite you know
um so yeah that's kind of a
circular answer but sorry
all right thank you so much
[Applause]